à l'arrivée alors attention choses
sérieuses aujourd'hui parce que là c'est
particulièrement taux de chiens depuis
quelques semaines le monde de la musique
est en émoi à la suite de la diffusion
au fameux festival sundance vous savez
ce festival pas vraiment de grandes mais
on va dire un petit peu quand même d'un
documentaire sur les abus sexuels
présumés de michael jackson ça fait
grand bruit
50 minutes inside sur tf1 est parti à la
rencontre de l'une des journalistes qui
a pu assister à la projection de ce film
très très très bien gardé parce qu'il
était très peu à pouvoir le voir on
regarde l'extrait et on sent par an
après et on en parle bien sûr dans ce
documentaire james échec et wade robson
révèle que michael jackson abusé d'eux
quand ils étaient enfants ils donnent
beaucoup de détails
les positions sexuelles préférés de
michael jackson l'endroit de neverland
où ces attouchements avait lieu un récit
jusque dans les moindres détails
glaçant c'était dévastateur j'en étais
malade de voir ça alors 300 spectateurs
triés sur le volet seulement pour
pouvoir voir ce film à sundance il y
avait je crois aussi des médecins des
psychologues prévu pour après la
projection éventuellement prendre en
charge
c'est très américain ça prends ma charge
les spectateurs qui avaient vu le film
un film qui dure quatre heures avec nous
dit on des révélations détonante
alors évidemment en france personne n'a
pu encore voir ce petit bijou mais ce
qu'on en sait un peu plus tout de même
sur ces fameuses accusateur les deux
accusateurs de de michael qui témoigne
dans ce film jeudi michael ces mecs
oui c'est très curieux ces coeurs
d'abord on peut être surpris de voir des
révélations presque dix ans après la
mort et quinze ans après le procès faut
quand même savoir que absolument oui qui
a duré très longtemps kaka est un
feuilleton pour la télé américaine où il
a d'ailleurs été blanchi de tous les
chefs d'accusation ce qui est très
curieux c'est justement un des
les accusateurs de ce film dont
marketing était bien lancée et est quand
même un de ceux qui avaient défendu
michael aller peindre avant à l'époque
donc c'est vrai que quand on sait qu'ils
demandent un milliard de dollars on se
dit qu'on est vraiment aux états unis
comme ça mais c'est vrai que on revient
un petit peu en cause ce jeune homme
maintenant devenu jeune homme parce
qu'effectivement à l'époque il avait été
un de ceux qui avaient permis de
blanchir et par ailleurs ensuite il a
voulu faire une chorégraphie enfin en
tout cas faire un spectacle sur michael
jackson dit peut-être d'engeances basser
que quand on parle des états unis 2 2 du
show biz et son parent toujours d'argent
et là entre deux très grosses sommes
donc évidemment alors on verra bien mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que le lancement de
ce documentaire il a été d'abord
justement va parler de ce procès très
médiatisé en 2005 on a vu michael
jackson faire face à de multiples chefs
d'accusation comment ça s'est passé à
l'époque alors c'était un grand
traumatisme pour lui parce que d'abord
ils étaient tous les jours devant les
caméras faudrait savoir qu aux etats
unis
il ya eu une une série télé qui était
faite à partir du process dire que
j'avais désaxé pire que ça il y avait
des acteurs à ouïr jouait les scènes de
la journée pour le lendemain
ryan chaîne de divertissement américaine
et puis lui il ya eu de la fameuse image
où en est on avec les mots note enfin
c'est un grand traumatisme et d'ailleurs
il n'a plus jamais et surtout ce qu'il a
de plus traumatisé c'est à la fin quand
son avocat a dit de toute façon on
client ne seras plus jamais seul sans
supervision avait des enfants
ça l'a dévasté parce que pour lui
justement tous ont tout le plaisir qu'il
avait d'être artiste était aussi d'être
proche des enfants morceau évidemment
comme on n'a pas le fin mot de
l'histoire
on peut imaginer qu'il était dévastée
s'il est innocent s'il ne l'était pas
bon est ce que michael jackson justement
a déjà évoqué ce procès où ces histoires
dans sa musique
alors oui une fois de façon assez des
tournées c'est sur l'album history qui
va avec la liste est longue ouverture il
ya un morceau qui s'appelle dsc les
initiales de domme sheldon qui est en
fait en presque la 3d de tom snedden qui
était le procureur voilà le biais comme
on dit aux états unis district attorney
qui avait voulu faire un procès pour la
première plainte d'enfance et où il ya
eu un arrangement avec 20 millions de
dollars ce qui fait que plein de gens
ont dit michael est coupable sinon
pourquoi il aurait payé mais c'est plus
compliqué que servent les états unis et
le deuxième procès c'était lui qui était
donc l'accusateur et qui n'a pas caché
le fait qu'il voulait se faire michael
jackson
et donc il était furieux qui en ont lieu
un acquittement
il est mort il ya quelques années et il
n'a jamais réussi à avoir avoir alors on
va terminer quand même sur une hauteur
de bien racontez nous un peu ce que
c'était que ce fameux ranch parce que
voilà tout le monde parle de ce ranch
nevada landes acheté par un michael
jackson en 88 pardonner vais revendre
pardon du nom du tout de pétrole alors
un petit peu parce que ça a été l'objet
de tous les fantasmes
on a raconté tout est presque n'importe
quoi en fait il a craqué de sueur à la
fin des années 80 il a acheté en 88 ça
lui a coûté très cher il a fait
construire c'est vraiment accès on dit
souvent c'est un cliché mais c'est vrai
il n'a pas eu d'enfance parce que quand
il avait 10 ans il tournait dans le
monde entier eh ben il a fait ce que
tout enfant rêve c'est à dire construire
son délire il y avait des tas il y avait
des singes avaient des lions il y avait
aussi des attractions qui d'ailleurs
pour certaines sont allées dans des
parcs d'attractions en californie parce
que depuis c'est très vendus et
justement à la suite du procès où il ya
vu une grande foule dans neverland
michael avait dit je n'habite serait
plus jamais ici ils ont violé le
sanctuaire en quelque sorte ça bien
c'était un peu son rêve d'enfant coates
ont préféré quand même pour terminer sur
une note musicale fera parler un peu de
la musique votre sacré on a tellement
thriller bad l'hostile drunk est une des
moins connus qui était très très belle
aussi dans les ballades comme dans les
morceaux de tempo c'est quelqu'un qui a
jamais été égalée qu'à une voix une
présence
et puis une capacité de danser de
chanter en même temps c'est de cesser
car option préférée de michael shields
world wish i do when we billie jean
billie jean damien iehl the world mais
bien sûr je lui tends km pokora ne fait
pas de reprise
c'est
il
[Applaudissements]
même dommage ces histoires parce qu'on
sera pas j'espère j'espère que qui
s'était rien passé
aucun enfant n'a vait été molestés
fabrique